points takes the match we're one and a
half one and a half tie the next win
it's match
over they're off it's game four and a
Queen's Gambit declined black not taking
on C4 it's the slav defense will we see
a repeat of game two of this uh Winner's
final no Dennis lavic switches things up
he pushes a pawn where earlier he
brought the White Knight out uh so
Magnus the first to pause um the first
to think we could see still see similar
positions transpositions but Magnus
regaining his composure here Tanya what
do you make of his body
language really uh and understandably it
seems to have affected Magnus it
definitely did we saw him at the end of
game three Magnus was angry he was
swearing right there he he couldn't
believe what had just happened we could
see that on the camera and now he's got
to come back but the one thing that's
scarier than Magnus is an angry Magnus
and that's what Dennis has to face right
now with the black Pie's Magnus going
for the slav he goes for this bishop G4
variation it's not one that I've played
with the black side Robert break down
the plans for us how do you see this one
progressing and is Magnus just trying to
stop the bleeding and take this to
Armageddon Magnus is taking the solid
approach because as we look at the pawn
triangle in the center black has all of
these pawns on light squares only white
has a light Square Bishop so for Magnus
Carlson you typically prefer to play
with the pair of Bishops as a high
level player but he's saying that I've
shut down open diagonals even Pawn
trades won't give it the full length of
the board that it would like to use to
its Advantage so I think Magnus he just
wants to play quickly he wants to play
solidly but David I mean look at his
face he is still bothered about what's
just
happened um understandably as we said
Magnus he's the number one he's the goat
for a reason and he's not used to being
in situations like this where a young
Pretender a young Rascal comes along and
uh kind of knocks him and kind of
threatens to kick him off his perch but
um yeah he needs to recover Magnus and I
think he's doing the right thing I like
Black's opening Choice here I like the
fact that Magnus has gone for this
really renowned solid variation because
ultimately Dennis doesn't want to take
too much risks either yes he's riding a
high yes he just beat Magnus but it's
not his style Dennis to kind of uh kind
of set the pace to be the one pushing
and pushing and kind of taking risks so
Magnus he's saying okay if you want to
win come at me uh I'm happy to just
recover and uh as you mentioned Robert
Rock Solid from black the pawn formation
the skeleton of Black's position no real
issues here yet at least um does have a
reputation I've played this myself of
being slightly passive for black again
white has the bishop pair in fact till
we talk about long term but uh
ultimately yeah this game I think it
could have gone worse for Magnus if he'd
uh kind of been too emotional and wanted
to strike back immediately so he's just
trying to uh now with this trade of
Pawns break open the center I'm
expecting Pawn to E5 now and he's trying
to neutralize Dennis try and get out of
this game and I don't think either of us
would complain right Tanya if uh we saw
nagon absolutely I think uh if this
match goes down to the Via if any match
deserve to go down to the V it is this
one and it's going to be a spicy armag
Gaden speaking about who wants to push
while Dennis isn't going to be a push
over in the Armageddon he's taken down
Anish gir he's taken down Maxim VRA in
the chessable Masters in the Armageddon
he's going to be taking a lot of
confidence from that the E5 break that
you were alluding to in the current
position I think that's definitely on
magnus's radar he's just preparing it a
little bit first falls back with that
Bishop white can start pushing his own
Central pawns try to take uh that space
with E4 which I think will be met by
your move E5
David on the board and uh at least E4 is
with a big big threat white wants to
play E5 so surely black has to stop it
here um that would be a for a double
attack if white steps forward one more
square and there we go Magnus does
indeed block and uh now okay Dennis
advances locking the center sometimes uh
not favorable if you have the bishop
pair but here it's all about control of
the light squares Magnus doesn't want to
allow white to sit with a protected pass
Pawn forever but if he ever trades on
the D5 Square White's light Square
Bishop will gain in power Robert I like
Dennis's last couple of moves he's
showing ambition here it looks nice for
white this bishop on C4 is a much better
piece than it was a few turns ago
because that pawn triangle all in light
squares blocking its diagonals that's no
more and it will open up towards the
black king at some point but look at
Magnus he says all right I concede that
your Bishop will be strong but how about
my Bishop on C5 how about some of the
control that my Knights will get this
Knight can wrap around to B6 at some
moment so both players they need to
figure out what the optimal squares are
for their p pieces and it's actually not
that easy one big decision is should
white take on C6 to isolate both of
Black's queenside pawns but isolated
polls open files an open B file could be
useful for black and that's why Dennis
he keeps the status quo and he maintains
a slight
pole I think this one is very likely
heading to that Armageddon that we're
looking at with that last trade and a
queen trade being offered to Magnus
you've been talking about body language
looking at him uh David I think this
game for for him is about calming down
and just knowing that you know with the
black pieces doesn't want to lose
control of anything and we take this uh
fight there but now the big question is
do you trade Queens especially against
Magnus
here normally I would say no don't do it
against the best endgame player of all
time the endgame Maestro himself but
here you do gain a bit of time
potentially he drops back though Dennis
lavic fearing those words maybe echoing
in his ears don't trade Queens against
Magnus but uh now at least the structure
changes and um Dennis I was going to say
is he going to take back with a pawn
maybe the most ambitious move but be
settled with an isolated Pawn of his own
uh or does he play it safe does he take
back on this square with a piece the
bishop the Knight sport for Choice here
and at least on the camera visibly
Magnus seems to have calmed down Robert
what do you make okay of this Knight
capture from
Dennis I thought we might get this
continuation because the risk associated
with isolating your own Pawn sure you
would have had a pass Pawn I don't think
that's Dennis's style I don't think he
wanted any part of that and this looks
very level and this move Queen back to
E7 it's so that when or if black takes
on D5 and The Rook takes back the queen
isn't hit so it's a bit of a
prophylactic move it's a defensive move
and I actually think that if Dennis
isn't careful Knights can outclass
bishops because this bishop is on its
optimal square but later down the line
if you can Envision a knight somewhere
out on a important dark Square maybe F4
maybe D4 it's a long ways away so I
don't think it's going to happen but
Knights can be very jumpy tricky pieces
so Dennis just can't assume it's going
to be a draw Magnus he typically plays
on if there's any life
left Magnus doesn't look too Lively
right now though too energetic um I
think if he wants to get this game
towards safety there we go he'll happily
trade off all the Rooks and uh Robert
that Dynamic you mentioned queen of
Knight versus queen and Bishop yeah
maybe some chances long term so Dennis
shouldn't relax too early never relax
against the top players of course but
ultimately Tanya I think your prediction
draw and Armageddon looks by far the
most likely outcome right now and you
mentioned Queen and Knight versus queen
and Bishop it gives chances to the side
with the Knight because they can get
tricky but if even the Queens come off
if it's just a pure Bishop versus knight
end game with pawns on both flanks it's
actually white with the bishop a
longrange piece that can start pushing a
little bit the king can come out the
bishop can be on D5 controlling more of
the board so it's really about who
manages to get the ideal trades in but I
think both players are making quick
moves quick improving moves and we are
going to see either the Queens come off
or the Rooks come off but I highly doubt
that this will head to a pure Bishop
versus knight because in that case
Dennis will be the one who'll be pushing
yeah that would not be good to get
Bishop versus knight I think that with a
knight where it currently sits it covers
many key squares and don't be surprised
when Magnus throws his H Pawn forward
right now is one option he could also
play on The Queen side I just feel like
some of Black's moves are a little bit
easier to play than whites this open D
file it looks just as strong as the open
C file but I I don't know something
about this position is making it
difficult for me to see what White's
actual plan is David do you see anything
for either side honestly and how you can
play for more than just
equality it's tough I think ultimately
the position is equal I would have said
actually until this last move that
Magnus is going to play his trademarks
he's going to play H5 just to tickle
pretend that he's pushing some pawns
forward on that flank towards the white
king then he might play A5 pretend he'll
push the B Pawn as well on the other
flank but I think magnus's mood is uh
different right now than it was earlier
in the day he's just happy to guide this
game towards safety and um yeah Rook to
D4 might be the only way to imbalance
things you pointed out there Robert on
the on the board Rook D4 would have
changed the pawn structure potentially
but uh now that the Rooks are off ah it
looks too symmetrical look at the pawn
structure prettyy much almost
symmetrical should still be a draw but
queen of Knight we
mentioned we choose black slightly if I
had to uh I wanted to ask the question
though assuming that this one stays
level who do you think is the happier
player and who do you think wants black
in the armag
garden wow that's uh that's a tough one
but I think it's a really important
question David because I think both
players will try and get the result odds
they will try to get the black pces but
then how low can you actually go to
attain that I don't know who's going to
win the Armageddon bid but I am
predicting a a bit around six and a half
minutes by these players what about you
Robert I think that Dennis yeah he has
shown a willingness to get low on the
clock he also just brought his King out
into the open you you can use your kings
as weapons in the end game everybody
although now black is aiming at a pawn
But to answer the Armageddon question I
think that Magnus he's willing to go
quite low he's been way faster
in this match thus far for
Dennis yeah I feel like seven minutes is
probably the lower limit just because he
constantly finds himself in time trouble
and he won't have increment to rely on
so I feel like Dennis will probably end
up with the white
pieces guys you got answer your question
too we're not going to let you off the
hook so easily I was about to deflect
and uh try to dodge that one um but I
agree I think uh both players will be
quite Keen especially Magnus now after
this last game to get the black pieces
Magnus lost with white so why not try to
get black um I also wanted to point out
the accuracy this game I mean it's such
a high class game and sometimes
ultimately a draw as a logical result in
chess 98% accuracy for both players um
yeah I think Magnus would love black and
he might go lower than we expect I think
he'll be super Keen to get the uh draw
odds but right now a pause for Magnus a
bit of a frown on the camera do you
think he'll try and uh grind this one we
keep saying tickle Dennis here creates
some threats Pawn H5 we predicted
actually both the Rooks pawns starting
to march here
Robert typical Magnus and he may even
throw that pawn one step further because
if white responds with G4 this may be
hard to visualize for some you're just
giving black all of the dark squares so
when your opponent has a knight and you
have a light Square Bishop how can you
control dark squares if your Pawn are on
dark squares since they capture
diagonally so you have to be very
careful here if you're Dennis Laz I know
that the bar is in the middle the draw
seems to be the likely result but I
we've seen it from Magnus countless
times in his illustrious career you take
one move off and suddenly you're in
trouble so does white stop that but give
black this very important G4 Square
looks of it worrisome to my eyes do you
allow black to play H4 and then harm
White's Pawn structure also looks
problematic I do think that Dennis has
to invest some serious time here and
he's already down almost 3 minutes on
the clock why should Magnus just make a
drw actually his latest move allows
black to play H4 this is risk-free chess
from the number one
player and on your point Robert Pawn to
H4 if it's ever captured uh Magnus will
smile he'll love that he'll happily
throw a pawn away white Pawn structure
will be totally ruined with Queens on
the board you cannot allow that the
black queen will happily at some point
sneak over towards the king side the
Black Knight will have access to some
Outpost so a lot of viewers at home
might be wondering why Pawn to H4 for
black it's a pawn sacrifice you're
giving it away but uh no you're breaking
the opponent's structure and wow I'm
really surprised Magnus didn't go for it
but oh okay no I'm showing I'm showing
what's happening if this game he did not
go for this maybe he's gonna go for it
later but I just wanted to you know
highlight that F4 and the dark squares
so B5 was play no I guess David you are
correct he didn't go for it but is it
going anywhere I guess is the question
Tanya I want to just highlight the idea
behind this last move B5 I think after
H4 Dennis tended to play Queen to C4
which is why he made this retreating
move Bishop to B3 we've been talking
about the different trades in the
position that how a queen trade would
actually favor white so B5 was a really
nice prophylactic move by Magnus taking
away a key Square which would have
forced the trade because it's not only
offering that Queen exchange but also
that F7 weakness uh which is why Magnus
did not rush with H4 played B5
controlling the square and now Dennis is
offering a bishop trade on D5 and I
think if Magnus picks this up are you
going to uh go into a King Pawn ending
will you calculate that well none of
that neither of the players want it
Magnus steps back attacking the H3 Pawn
the king comes back and we're expecting
that move H4 to land about
now asle if Magnus wants to win this
game or if he wants to keep any winning
chances alive but feels like hesitation
here Robert indecision from the world
number one Magnus just drops his King
back doesn't necessarily improve things
he's coming towards the center hinting
he might take the white Bishop but still
yet to go for that H4 um why do you
think he's waiting why isn't he pulling
the trigger and going for it well thank
you for the hint because I was thinking
that Knight takes D5 made White's life
easy but you're absolutely correct that
especially if the Queens come off there
the black king can Dart to the center
and black may just win the pawn where it
lands on D5 so white needs to be very
careful I'm not so sure about some of
these decisions from both players
frankly but the pawn on B4 is it a
weakness is it a Str strength you do get
a Pawn on a dark Square your Bishop
can't help defend that later on but that
also freezes Black's Pawn on a light
Square so your Bishop can go after that
this is Magnus Carlson will he push will
he press Tanya it does feel like his
style of endgame here but is there
enough life left and that's the big
question is there enough life left are
there enough pieces left and to my eyes
it just feels like you don't have enough
resources to make that much of it but
that said with this bishop on D5 still
underpin with this bishop on D5 always
this trade being offered I think this is
the best position that Magnus has had
all game and it just comes down to how
ambitious will he feel does he want to
play this out till the very end does he
want to go into an Armageddon or is
danovic getting ambitious F4 was not a
move on my
radar robt I see the expression on your
face I think it matches mine I mean this
feels desperate F4 looks ambitious but
it's also going to weaken the white king
the white porn structure is never going
to be intact anymore huge huge gamble
there from Dennis Laz with two minutes
left and I think for Dennis he was tired
of sitting and waiting feeling like
Magnus was getting the upper hand slowly
but surely but F4 here and even if you
swap pawns on this square that now the
dark squares are really vulnerable and a
move like Queen C7 maybe you could start
with Queen C7 in some of these positions
as well because the white king is
exposed also on the second rank so I
don't know about that decision the EV uh
engine the evaluation bar it says that
it was incorrect but maybe it will pay
off because it does muddy the water so
it's not just one-sided in magnus's
favor idea on the board I like the fact
that Dennis pre moved G takes F4 because
every second counts at this point down
to two minutes and que C7 hitting that
pawn just hinting it coming in and
behind that's the most uncomfortable
thing in chess when an opponent's Queen
is down uh kind of in your gr down on
the first second ranks and uh I mean
pretty much Unstoppable the black queen
is coming in One Direction or the other
yes white can go and take the B5 Pawn
but you might just get checkmated along
the way so um you have to be really
careful now this is where Queen and
Knight if they get to attack together
will be so dangerous right Tanya White's
Bishop might not be able to participate
in the defense on the dwar yeah some
really big committal decisions taken by
danis the last couple of moves and I
think what he's calculating right now is
can he Force matters can he go E5
forcing the trade on D3 but you have to
be really careful uh for sorry forcing
the trades on D5 you have to be super
careful because that allows Black's
Queen to infiltrate you might lose the
A3 Pawn with checks and then are you in
time to give perpetuals he doesn't go
for it he falls back with the queen
defending that F4 Pawn Robert you don't
like this move well the blue arrow tells
the full story here Queen D6 freezes
white the queen went to the pawn f4s
defense a queen on D6 threatens Knight
takes E4 because the bishop on D5 is
pinned and in certain end games you can
even just take this bishop on D5 King E7
it was a miss this deserves the X
sometimes I throw that X out the window
and say no that's a perfectly fine move
Queen D6 not easy to play because using
a pin but walking into potential forks
and things of that nature are not easy
but I do feel like Dennis is in trouble
here I don't really care what the engine
says it's the the position of the white
king it's that the white pieces feel a
bit clumsy
he needs to do something fast otherwise
he's just going to lose he's also down
now to just 53 52
seconds we saw the first clue as well
that Dennis is getting nervous on the on
the camera uh I'm just watching him
there there was a slight almost
imperceptible Shake of the head suddenly
scratching his head as well he's
realizing oh there's no natural moves
and 40 seconds left again the clock is
ticking Magnus inserting the upper hand
yet again on the clock and Tanya you
mentioned it when you're low on time
it's natural you want to force the issue
and he's going for it now he's trying to
force the trade of Knight for Bishop
what do you think is this going to save
Dennis well the evalar helps us turns
out that it is a right moment and the
right decision the big question to me at
that moment was that if black was to
capture on D5 give checks with the queen
when black wins that A3 Pawn that Side
Pawn that white has can Black's King be
under danger are there enough checks is
there a Perpetual but I think with
magnus's King now placed on E7 these
lines work out for Dennis he's just
going to capture the D5 Pawn Magnus if
he comes in with the queen starts
getting greedy I think there's a
Perpetual against the E7 King here
there's just one thing that Dennis needs
to be alert about if he brings his King
to the third rank there could be a
sneaky check on B3 trying to create a
pass Pawn so Dennis he has a drawing
mechanism of his own the black king is
in actually in a bad position because
once the black queen leaves Queen D6 to
B8 and back to D6 you put it on a yo-yo
string it's going to deliver a draw but
Magus he poses a really challenging
question to Dennis now can you trade
Queens because that could be a losing
King and pwn in game and Dennis has 30
seconds to figure it
out wow what a tough decision now Dennis
he has to risk either he has to trust
Magnus and Dodge the queen trade or he
has to risk a king and porn end game
Queen to C5 check instead I think a wise
decision if in doubt take the safer
option king of por games are pure
calculation it's move by move you're
either winning or losing drawing like
nothing in between you can't just wing
it so Queen to C5 check now the black
king uh Tanya you mentioned it's not
entirely safe do you think it's gonna
step forward is Magnus gonna be feeling
brave wow there we go he answers the
question for me and a mistake by Denis
he moves his own King forward but this
gives Magnus the time to actually
infiltrate with his Queen and now I
think the point is that he can go Pawn
hunting because black king is going to
March up the light squares and be safe
and then might not be a Perpetual then
that's exactly what's happening here but
the players they don't have any blue
arrows they don't have an evaluation bar
to the side telling them that this is
the moment but for Dennis lack he's been
hanging on by a thread for the last
bunch of moves here Queen D3 check and
as you said t the King by thread and
needle can use those light squares and
it is going to be a problem for white
and King G3 what a natural move to play
to avoid any kind of queen trade Queen
D5 was going to offer Queen trade with
Black's King in a favorable spot David
will Magnus find Queen D3 first and King
F5 second yes because Robert I want to
point out don't play King F5 now if you
play King F5 enter with the black king
you lose on the spot the white Pawn will
step forward to E6 with a discovered
check and you have to retreat with the
King taking this Pawn you get mated in
the center of the board so process of
elimination you cannot Advance your king
first you have to go for a check and
only then once your queen is safe drive
forward with your own King it's a race
between Kings right now and uh Magnus we
think we he's gonna go for it do you see
the blue arrow here G5 check I assume if
Pawn takes there might be Queen C4 is
that one of those ideas that you can
play to force the Queens off the board
and get a pass Pawn that is incredibly
deep and it goes to show that pawn
quality it often outpaces Pawn quantity
and especially end game like this G5
check is played I'm going to freak out
because that just looks impossible there
are no Protectors of that square and
white has two pieces covering it we're
all going to fall out of our chairs if
G5 check is played but Magnus has 25
seconds always look for check first
that's the moral of the story either
they're very good or you rule them out
and you look for something uh better but
okay he's really going low on the clock
he plays the more natural move King to
F5 missed opportunity maybe winning
there some checkmates or queen trades
and now wow blue arrow says the best
move to keep the balance the only move
is to give away the pawn and Dennis has
done it he's going for Perpetual check
can the black king escape from the white
Queen's gaze right now o no more checks
suddenly why ises he sacrificed the pawn
why is this genius because of the King
march now is Dennis being brave and
adventurous with the white
king yeah I I didn't see another check
and I was really surprised but like you
said the black queen needs to defend all
these checks and he goes Pawn hunting
but now there's got to be a Perpetual
now you start just checking the king and
you don't allow Black's Queen you
probably give a check from C5
making sure that the black queen cannot
come to
defense he does
that we got to be careful Dennis the
black queen can swoop back to block some
of these checks as she just does there
and Dennis did he miss that one he lent
back in his chair two seconds he's
playing purely on the increment now
shaking his head the black king is going
to slide away slink away to safety and
the white king might get checkm be
careful here it's a queen trade what an
offer and it's a draw so it was
brilliant by Dennis LZ apparently this
is a hold but not after that move he had
to play B5 a moment ago now it's too
slow start a race Dennis lazic but he
had no time to calculate shaking his
head now the black porns are going to
March forward to Victory heartbreak he
was one accurate move away so close but
Magnus is going to do it endgame magic
again there we go
Magnus he does it he gets the win in and
that was